c'est un ministre de l'éducation
nationale que les enseignants ont
beaucoup entendu parler ils ont pu
reconnaître que du coup on on parlait
éducation nationale dans les médias en
politique dans l'opinion publique mais
c'est aussi des enseignants qui se sont
très vite aperçus que ces grand discours
n'étit pas suivi d' faits dans leur
quotidien et que leur quotidien restait
extrêmement extrêmement difficile et et
c'est vrai que c'est notamment ça qui
montait au mois de décembre de plus en
plus de collègues qui nous disaient mais
est-ce que ce ministre est vraiment le
ministre de notre quotidien c'était une
question mais quelque part poser la
question c'est déjà y répondre c'est
même très difficile de faire un bilan en
en 5 mois on a du mal à à trouver une
trace très concrète du passage de
Gabriel Atal rue de Grenel certes il y a
eu beaucoup d'annonces c'est finalement
Gabriel Attal a été le le ministre de
l'opinion public plus que le ministre
des des enseignants puisqu'il a pu nous
parler de l'uniforme
il a pu nous parler de de l'autorité des
enseignants il a pu nous parler de la
lutte contre le harcèlement au milieu
scolaire mais dans les faits
concrètement sur le terrain on est
toujours aussi démuni sur la question de
la lutte contre le harcèlement au milieu
scolaire on a des professeurs qui
continuent de se faire menacer remettre
en cause on a on manque toujours de
professeurs dans dans les classes au
mois de de décembre on avait encore des
classes où il manquait des des
professeurs euh bref le le quotidien des
enseignants n'a pas changé avec ave
Gabriel Adal il a beaucoup d'annonces
qui qui sont cohérentes dans l'idée de
de transformer le collège euh d'en faire
un lieu où finalement on pourrait
séparer les les élèves en fonction de
leur niveau euh c'est c'était quand même
un sacré retour en arrière euh c'était
finalement tourner le dos à à une forme
de
démocratisation du système éducatif par
le collège les groupes de niveau nous on
y est farouchement opposé comme d'autres
organisations syndicales d'ailleurs et
et malgré tout Gabriel Attal a avancé on
y est opposé parce que il y a cette idée
que ben finalement on mélange plus les
élèves on ne fait plus du commun on
apprend plus ensemble alors qu'on sait
que l'éducation nationale le collège le
lycée sont quand même des lieux où on
apprend ensemble l'uniforme c'est je
dirais c'est c'est le symbole du passage
de Gabriel Atal rue de Grenel euh c'est
une annonce très médiatique c'est une
annonce qui parle certainement à
l'électorat conservateur d'Emmanuel
Macron mais c'est pas une annonce qui
parle aux enseignants euh aujourd'hui
quand on est professeur le problème
c'est pas de savoir si l'élève porte un
polo bleu ou un polo rouge le problème
c'est de savoir si il va avoir les
bonnes conditions pour progresser s'il
va être dans une classe où il y a pas
trop d'élèves et surtout s'il a un
professeur formé en face de lui à notre
sens la la question mérite d'être posée
euh c'est vrai que ça a été un passage
un passage éclair qui lui a permet qui
lui a permis d'aller plus vite plus haut
euh on se rend bien compte que il a il a
fait beaucoup d'annonces qui servaient à
se construire une stature politique la
stature la stature politique d'un homme
qui parle qui parle à l'opinion publique
et ça lui a permis de de sortir du du
relatif anonymat des comptes publics à
Bery et et forcément on se pose la
question de savoir si ce ce tourbillon
d'annonce il était pas aussi et d'abord
destiné à se construire cette cette
stature politique pour pour aller plus
haut et plus
loin